what I want to try and explain over the
next 10 minutes or so is arriving 10
minutes oh okay
over the next few minutes or so I'll
start again what I'd like to explain
over the next few minutes or so is why
so materials are transparent and others
are completely opaque while I can get
through some materials while I can't get
through other materials in particular
glass
what makes glass transparent why can
light get through this
yeah I found a number of interesting and
disturbing websites I guess so I thought
given that was doing the sixty symbols
video and looking on boy glasses
transparent I thought let's just google
it and see what everybody else says and
type in ways glass transparent into
Google and you get a number of sites
which just give you completely incorrect
answers completely wrong and answers
disturbingly wrong in that they explain
it in terms of well glass is like a
liquid and the molecules don't pack as
tightly as they do in a solid and
therefore there are gaps in there in in
glass that the light can get through
that is wrong badly wrong on so many
different levels yeah so what is going
on is its with with glass compared to
other materials the important thing is
how the atoms are arranged in that in
the solid and how the atoms are arranged
dictates and this is the really
important bit how the electrons are
arranged and its how those electrons
stack up in different energy levels or
the energies of those electrons that
dictates whether light can get through
right so what I'm going to do now is I'm
going to pretend to be a photon I'm
going to move through this room and this
room represents a substance lots of
atoms electrons dotted around everywhere
so I'm moving through with a certain
amount of energy and my job as a photon
is actually to take one of these
electrons from its ground state its
lowest energy State move it up and bring
it up to a higher energy level and when
I do that busy my job is done and I'm
absorbed and I don't make it through the
solid so if it's brick for example this
is what happens that the photon comes
through it takes an electron from the
ground state moves it to a higher energy
level as absorbed doesn't make a true
the substances of pick four glass and
other special materials where which are
transparent instead of what happens is
that the difference in energy between
the ground state and the high the high
energy level which we call the energy
gap is much too large and as a photon
I'm coming through what I need to do or
what I to be absorbed what I need to do
is actually take one of these
electrons and bring it all the way up
here to this excited energy level but I
don't have enough energy to do that I
simply can't get it up there
so for therefore I'm not absorbed and I
pass through the material getting at the
other side and so the PT realign appears
transparent so the energy difference
between the ground state and this level
it the difference between those two we
call an energy gap and an electron can
only either be here or here it cannot
exist in between we cannot excited that
so the photon gives up that energy and
transfers first there and then it's the
photon basically is dead so when it
comes to glass and diamonds and other
transparent materials that energy gap
between the ground state and that
excited level is so large that photons
of visible light photons with visible
wavelengths photons that we can see have
not got enough energy to actually get it
from here all the way up there right so
now we're going to go down the lab and
I'm actually going to do an experiment
or look at an experiment the second year
undergraduates do here which is to look
at how light is absorbed in these
materials we have a light source we have
something called a monochromator
monochromator some terms as how it's
pronounced and what that does is from
the white light source it selects out a
particular wavelength of light a
particular color of light particular
energy of light and so this at the
moment is telling us that the wavelength
of this light is roughly I haven't done
the calibration so I'm assuming it's
right
roughly 525 nanometers and so I'm going
from at this point high-energy photons
but this blue green color up to low
energy photons so what we have here is a
sample now this is sort of midway
between what we've been talking it's not
quite completely opaque it's not quite
completely transparent you can see it's
colored it's orange so an example of
something called a semi conductor what's
interesting about this semiconductor is
that that energy gap falls in the
visible range means that some photons of
light in the visible have enough energy
to excite those electrons whereas others
don't and we can actually measure that
transition from where the photons have
enough energy to where they don't have
enough energy or alternatively where the
photons get blocked because they have
enough energy compared to where they
actually get transmitted the hole which
so what I'm going to do now is here it's
just the leg just so we could see it
I've put on the side of the of the box
that contains the photodiode this is
actually the active part so what I'm
going to do here so I'm going to move
this across and put it on the photodiode
and now we see late getting true what
I'm going to do is put this sample in
there I'm going to put it in front of
the photodiode so the light is coming
true from here true here true here true
me going through the sample now and
ending up on the photodiode and you can
see that we've got zero and the reason
we've got zero lay coming true now is
that all the photons are absorbed
because photons of this energy have
enough energy to promote electrons to
excite electrons across that gap so
they're absorbed so they don't get true
when we change the energy so we're going
from the blue to the red the DIYer will
start to come up because at that point
the light is now getting true because at
this point the photons no longer have
enough energy to actually get through
the sample because we're not promoting
those electrons from the ground state to
the excited level